uh
so
okay
hello
oh yeah
good night
oh
no
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
um
oh my goodness just thinking around the
government
questions
thank you
how are you
my best friends
stuff
okay
oh
yes
um
um
[Music]
is
yes
thank you
um
it is
i'm listening
okay
well
hey
so
so
okay a couple of updates for you all
at the top here uh after the president
is briefed by his coven 19 response team
this afternoon
he will speak to the american people
about the strong progress that the
country has made in recovery because of
its robust
vaccination campaign as well as the
importance of every eligible american
getting vaccinated especially as the
delta variant continues to grow among
unvaccinated people across the country
by the end of the week the united states
will be nearing 160 million people
fully vaccinated which the president
will touch on today as well
which is critically important as fully
vaccinated people are protected against
the delta variant he will also stress
how the administration will continue its
effort to work with governors local
leaders
and across the public and private sector
to get more americans vaccinated
by making vaccines available in more
health care settings and respond
to hot spots president will outline five
areas
his team is focused on to get more
americans vaccinated
one targeted community by community
door-to-door outreach
to get remaining americans vaccinated by
ensuring they have the information they
need
on how both safe and accessible the
vaccine is two
a renewed emphasis on getting the
vaccines to more primary care
doctors and physicians something that
we've seen as a very
successful tactic uh with reaching
groups
with lower vaccination rates in the past
few months
three stepped up efforts which is
complementary to my last point
to get vaccines to pediatricians and
other providers who serve younger people
so that adolescents age 12 to 18 can get
vaccinated as they go for back to school
checkups
or get ready for fall sports four
continue exhibiting efforts to make the
vaccine accessible for workers
access as an area where we've seen as a
challenge and one where as we've worked
to address it we've seen increasing
rates so that includes setting up
vaccination clinics at workplaces
and pto or time leave that employees can
take off
to get vaccinated and finally expanding
our mobile clinic efforts meeting people
where they are
and making sure we're taking the vaccine
to communities another coveted update
this week both guatemala and vietnam
will be receiving covet vaccine
doses from the biden harris
administration guatemala will receive
1.5 million doses of moderna and vietnam
will receive 2 million doses of moderna
also today as part of the president's
forthcoming executive order on
competition stay tuned
the u.s department of agriculture
announced it will engage in a series of
rule makings
to increase competition in agricultural
industries
to boost farmers and ranchers earnings
fight back against abuses of power by
giant agribusiness corporations
and give farmers the right to repair
their own equipment how they like
the president's executive order will
follow through on a campaign promise by
directing usda
to issue new rules under the packers and
stockyards act
making it easier for farmers to bring
and win claims stopping chicken
processors from exploiting and
underpinning chicken farmers
and adopting anti-retaliation
protections for farmers who speak
out about bad practices second the eo
will
directs usd the usda to issue new rules
defining when meat can bear product of
the usa labels
so that consumers have accurate
transparent labels that enable them to
know where their food comes from
and to choose to support american
farmers and ranchers
something i learned that i found a
little outrageous we'll see what you all
think is that
under current labeling rules most
grass-fed beef labeled product of
usa is actually raised and slaughtered
abroad and then imported to the us for
processing the president and the usda
believe it is unfair for domestic
farmers and ranchers to have to compete
with foreign companies
that are misleading consumers third
the eo directs usda to develop a plan to
increase opportunities for farmers
to access markets and receive a fair
return including supporting
alternative food distribution systems
like farmer farmers markets and
developing standards and labels that
consumers can choose to buy products
that treat farmers
and agricultural workers fairly these
are just a few
examples of actions usda will take under
the new executive order
and in the entire federal government's
mission which will be helped
move forward through this executive
order to help increase opportunities for
small and independent businesses
to boost their earnings and to lower
prices increase options for
consumers i think i have one more item
uh
yes a number of you had asked me on the
last trip i was on
if we could do a little more to preview
trips farther in advance so i'm going to
try to do that today
as you all know tomorrow the president
will travel to crystal lake illinois
which is located in the district of
congresswoman lauren underwood
there he will visit mchenry county
college a community college that has a
workforce development program
and a child care center programs which
is build back better agenda invests in
and the american families plan we've
talked quite a bit in here
has proposals in as the president
presses for the bipartisan
infrastructure framework
he's also pressing ahead on a dual track
for the full breadth and scope
of the build back better agenda which
includes his climate uh
his critical climate priorities and the
american families plan
the president's buildback better agenda
provides a once in a generation
investment
in the foundations of middle class
prosperity education
healthcare and child care from making
education more affordable and expanding
key provisions like the child care tax
credit
to providing economic security through
programs like paid leave to families
the president will continue advancing
his entire economic agenda to build back
better
congresswoman underwood many of you may
know is a registered nurse
health policy expert and committed
advocate for expanding access to high
quality
affordable health care which the
buildback better agenda accomplishes by
permanently lowering health insurance
premiums
for those who build coverage on their
own saving families an average of fifty
dollars per person per month
as a result nine million people would
save hundreds of dollars per year on
their premiums and four million
uninsured people
would gain coverage he'll also of course
engage with elected officials on the
ground we'll have an update for you as
the schedule is being finalized on that
that's it why don't you kick us off
thanks jen uh first uh respect
for the coveted speech this happened um
that rate of that new vaccination in the
u.s has been continuously declining over
the last 12 months since
access has increased as promotions
giveaways
all sorts of efforts from the
administration practice to get people to
get vaccinated
that's a threat as well is there a point
for the administration where
you know for people where they were
something that people have not been
vaccinated
are choosing not to and then the
administration will stop sort of you
know
throwing money at them or giving
speeches encouraging them get vaccinated
if that's their choice
well first let me say zeke that we had
always
noted that at a certain phase uh in the
vaccination process or in our fight
against covid
when we had more supply than we had
demands which was about two months a
month and a half ago
that we the numbers would go down in
terms of the number of people who are
vaccinated each day and each week
more than two million people per week
are getting their first dose and
millions more are getting their second
dose
so our focus now is on doubling down on
our efforts as we continue to vaccinate
millions of people across the summer
months
and that includes as we've noted um in
here in the past
young people under the age of 27 who are
being vaccinated at a lower
rate than people who are 27 and older
and we could believe that we need to
continue to press to get more people in
the country vaccinated even as we're
seeing rates
in parts of the country that are over 70
even some places over 80 percent
there's still more work to be done you
are absolutely correct that is
ultimately upped individuals to decide
if they were going
if they are going to get vaccinated if
you're vaccinated you are
uh most the vast vast majority of people
are safe from the virus uh if you are
not vaccinated
you are not that is also a message that
we're going to continue to clearly uh
communicate but no
these programs will continue and we're
going to continue to
press forward on approaches that we have
seen work in the past
gears to this massive cyber attack
is the president's view of just
philosophy that it's the role of
government to protect businesses and
private citizens from aggressive cyber
actions like this
are there cyber attacks like this
ransomware or is it
an issue of personal or corporate
responsibility what's that sort of
is there a ratio the president needs to
decide is it the eighty percent you know
on the government to present for that
days
what's the next well zeke i would first
say that the
the attack over the weekend underscores
the need for companies and government
agencies
as well to focus on improving cyber
security and we've talked a bit in the
past about
the importance of private sector
entities hardening their own
cyber security putting in place best
practices that have been recommended
by the federal government for some time
but we are going to continue to be
partners
because it's important to of course
protect our critical infrastructure
uh but also protect uh to do it to play
what role we can from the federal
government
to ensure that impacts on uh smaller
businesses on mom and pop shops are
are minimized as well so uh we have
engaged over the last
several months under the leadership of a
range of officials including ann
neuberger
in a better partnership more effective
partnership with the private sector
providing resources from the federal
government uh and we'll continue that
reports that calvin selman is in town uh
in washington this week
potentially meet with jake sullivan can
you confirm that that meeting and then
also is the confirmation of the white
house
believes that he had no role in the
murder of journalists
uh well i can confirm that meeting let
me see i believe i have a little bit
more information on it here one moment
for you zeke
um saudi arabia's deputy defense
minister will meet
with or is meeting with i should say uh
by administration officials today
including national security adviser
jake sullivan um he's scheduled to meet
with state and
defense department officials as well
during the meeting they'll discuss the
long-standing partnership
between the united states and saudi
arabia regional security and the u.s
commitment to help
saudi arabia defend its territory as it
faces attacks from iranian-aligned
groups
as you know we worked to declassify a
report that named specific officials
who we felt or who the our intelligence
community i should say were involved
with and
knowledgeable of the horrific death of
jamal khashoggi beyond that i can tell
you that
of course this could be a topic but i'm
not going to discuss additional details
i'll go ahead yeah i just want to follow
up on the casino attack
sure have you had any communication at
all with russia about this attack
i'm going to ask a few more questions
but
president putin and president biden met
and discussed cyber security
were you under the impression that putin
would do more
to prevent these kind of attacks so
first let me say let me give you a
little bit of an update since the
meeting between president biden and
president putin we have undertaken
expert level talks that are continuing
and we expect to have another meeting
next week focused on ransomware attacks
uh and i
will just reiterate a message that these
officials are sending
as the president made clear to president
putin when they met if the russian
government cannot
or will not take action against criminal
actors residing in russia
we will take action or reserve the right
uh to take action
uh on our own uh now in this case um
you know their uh the intelligence
community has not yet attributed the
attack uh the cyber security
community agrees that our evil operates
out of russia with affiliates around the
world
so we will continue to allow that
assessment to continue
but in our conversations and we have
been in touch directly
we are continuing to convey that message
clearly so you've been in touch directly
with at what level of government have
you been in touch with russia on this
specific
issue and then um on the ransomware
um the fbi has basically told companies
not to pay ransomware are you aware
whether in this particular case the
ransom of 70 million dollars
has been paid in what advice are you
giving to the company
and um earlier today the ceo
said that the you know the critical
infrastructure was never at risk is that
do you share that assessment
uh sure well let me try to take two of
your questions and you can tell me if i
missed one um
uh on ransomware uh our uh our uh well
what was your first question in the
order where have you been in touch uh
high level of our national security team
has been in touch uh
with uh high level of russian officials
uh on your second question
repeat it again now
our ransom where policy continues to be
uh
the same as it has been for several
months which is that we do not advise we
advise against in fact
companies paying ransomware given it
incentivizes uh
bad actors to repeat this behavior in
terms of whether the company has paid
ransom
i would refer you to the company uh and
in terms of assessments of the impact
uh we certainly um uh
would we saw the company put out an
extensive statement
uh today about what the impacts uh were
on our systems and we certainly uh defer
to them on the impacts
i am at switchgears we have a story
through a company
of organizations like the chamber of
commerce the national association
manufacturers international retail
federation are carrying a perfect
lobbying campaign
to you know lobby against the tax
increases that you
are proposing and what they say
is that increasing taxes doesn't create
jobs what do you say to that and
you know are you what are you doing to
counter this pretty
you know intense push by these loving
organizations
well first i would say that um the
american people
are aligned with the president's view
that corporations
and the wealthiest americans can afford
to pay a little bit more
in order to uh pay for critical
investments
in our nation's infrastructure but also
in
initiatives and programs that will help
uh make
our country more competitive and bring
more women back into the workforce and
that's what the president
is proposing i would also note that
we've seen
in terms of public reports that of the
the wealthiest companies out there a
number of them didn't pay any taxes
at all uh and that certainly is not
something that
is viable nor does the president think
that is fair and that
uh sends a clear message that our tax
system is not
set up in a fair and equitable way and
that's something he feels we should
address regardless
uh so that's his view in his proposal
we'll have to see how successful these
lobbyists are at moving the
uh public opinion and approval rating uh
down from
what it is currently which is the vast
majority of the american people agree
with the president
go ahead um just one quick follow-up on
ransomware and then two other quick ones
from a response perspective if this is
attributed to
our evil and they decide that it's based
in russia
is the president's view that the
response will be proportional to
just taking that actor offline or
actually directed at the russian state
instead for harvard how do you guys
approach that
it's a good question phil i would say
that i'm not going to be able to detail
more specifics from here but i would
note that
and i would reiterate that the
president's view and the
administration's view
is that even as it is criminal actors
who are taking these actions against the
united states
or or entities private sector entities
in the united states
even as even without the engagement of
the russian government they still have a
responsibility that continues to be the
president's view and the
administration's view
in terms of what actions we may or may
not take uh
we'll i'll allow the national security
team to work that through and then
can you two more equipment what's the
level of frustration in the white house
that
you have a vaccine the vaccine works it
is available
to a degree it has never been available
before people are not getting the
vaccine and therefore the delta variant
is emerging in certain places around the
country
are you guys banging the table are you
upset how do you
kind of go through that knowing that
there is a counter
weapon here to what's happening around
the country you know phil i think as
um as the federal government uh we don't
have the luxury of
feeling frustrated or feeling um upset
about individuals not getting the
vaccine what our responsibility is
is to ensure we are applying best
practices whether that's working with
doctors and pediatricians or or
addressing access
mobile vaccine clinics or ensuring that
people know
that they can take time off of work or
even working with employers to make the
vaccine accessible
it is ultimately up to individuals and
we certainly recognize that as well
but we're going to continue to press as
hard as we can
to use the best practices to continue to
increase the vaccination rates around
the country
and just one more quick one opec plus i
just said a statement yesterday that you
guys are directly engaged
with the various players even though
you're not a part of the negotiation can
you elaborate a little bit on what that
means sure uh we are closely monitoring
the opec plus negotiations and their
impact on the global economic
recovery from the coven 19 pandemic as
you noted phil we're not a party to
these talks
but over the weekend and into this week
we've had a number of
high-level conversations with officials
in saudi arabia the uae and other
relevant partners
we're encouraged by the ongoing
conversation by opec members to
reaching an agreement the ongoing talks
i should say uh which will promote
access to affordable and reliable energy
and certainly the impact on
prices here is uh hence our great
interest go ahead
i just want to follow up on zeke's
question to you on this sort of
public private role uh in response sure
to cybertech so
you know the president signed these
orders back in may um some of which were
of course supposed to step up
enforcement on private companies at
least as
those that work with the federal
government but it's been 55 days since
we signed those orders and from our
review the orders from dhs haven't been
put in place yet
they're still actually in the review
process so
is these attacks are happening still
though is the government working
fast enough on even in the narrow lane
where you say you can do some work
well i would say first the the increase
in ransomware attacks
far predated the president taking office
and it is something that
uh from day one he has made a priority
and has asked his team to
focus on where we can have an impact how
we can better work with the private
sector
and what we can do across the federal
government to help address
and reduce ransomware attacks on our
critical infrastructure but also on
a range of entities in the united states
um
tomorrow the president will convene key
leaders across the inter-agency
including the state department
department of justice dhs
and other intelligence community members
of the intelligence committee to discuss
ransomware and our overall strategic
efforts to counter it
and what he had asked the team to do
several weeks ago was to
review and assess uh what our options
are
and how we can better again put in place
partnerships with the private sector
best practices what levers we have from
the federal government
including disruption of ransomware
infrastructure and actors which we've
seen some
success in i know the department of
justice announced some steps just a few
weeks ago
building international coalition to hold
countries
who harbor ransom actors accountable
which is a huge factor here as well
because we're not the only country
impacted of course by uh ransomware and
tax expanding cryptocurrency analysis
to find and pursue criminal transactions
and reviewing our own ransom policies to
build cohesive and consistent approaches
toward ransom payments so this is a
priority he's meeting with a range of
officials tomorrow
and we will continue to implement moving
forward but would you say you're still
in the review and assessment phase
well i would first note that we have
announced several steps that we have
taken i mean the department of justice
announced a step just a few weeks ago uh
and we are continuing to up
our partnership with the private sector
which is a key part of
best practices and ensuring we are
reducing uh the impact uh
the i should say the vulnerability of
private sector entities
uh but there is more that can be done
and it warrants and requires an
interagency process and discussion in
order to move
those policies forward go ahead thank
you a quick follow-up on the ransom sure
you mentioned that after president biden
caught on putin
to hold cyber hackers accountable there
have been expert level talks
is there any evidence that putin has
done anything to
curb um cyber attacks in russia
that he's communicated with the us well
like again i would say it's a little bit
just proving a negative there because
this is what we're talking about here is
ransomware attack attack from likely
criminal actors again it hasn't been
fully attributed yet so we're getting a
little bit ahead which i certainly
understand
of where things stand uh there are these
expert level talks and
negotiations and engagements that's an
important part of the next
steps an important part of what came out
of their discussion
uh and beyond that i think what the
messages that the president has
sent clearly and what we are sending
continuing to say clearly is
even with these criminal actors uh we're
not saying they're coming from the
government or directed from the
government but even with those actors
they have a responsibility
so that's where the policy is moving
forward i i think it's difficult for me
to
uh this proven negative um and on covet
the
five-step plan you outlined still focus
have focuses heavily on access
and you've already mentioned the group
of people who have access to the vaccine
but simply
don't want it so is the white house
tweaking its strategy
to reach those people to change their
minds
i wouldn't say it's about changing their
minds what we have seen over the course
well i guess it sort of is but what
we've seen over the course of time is
that
the most reliable uh voices are
trusted actors and communities medical
experts doctors people's primary care
physicians
and so we're going to continue to
utilize and resource
the entities where we feel there has
been success and where we've seen
through data
there has been success in the past you
know you don't just give up just because
you haven't reached every single person
we're going to continue to apply
where we what we've seen have been the
best practices over the past several
months
and just one more question if the number
of cases
continues to trend upward are there any
circumstances under which
the white house would reimpose some of
those restrictions
as cases tick up or would that be up to
the states
well states are going to have to make
evaluations and local communities are
going to have to make evaluations about
what's in their interests and as you
know there are
much higher rates of vaccinations in
some parts of the country over others
and we certainly support
their decisions to implement any
measures that they think will help their
communities safe
but i would remind you we're at a point
where we're almost at percent
vaccination
rate for uh we will for twenty adults
twenty seven and older but almost for
adults eighteen and older so
uh certainly we don't see we're on track
to implementing new additional national
measures go ahead
on ransomware the company statement goes
into a lot of detail about the kinds of
victims
among its client base and points out
that they are not related to
critical infrastructure is that simply
about informing people about what's
there or is that to
separate this attack from some of the uh
the outline the president
presented to vladimir putin about uh
sort of the no-go list
of critical infrastructure that should
not be
interfered with from any russian actor
be it criminal or state or whatever do
you see that as an important tell
well i would say that um of course
there's a unique
threat posed by cyber attacks that
disrupt critical infrastructure
and there's no question about that if
there's a cyber attack that takes out an
entire sector of the american economy
that would have
an enormous broad impact and we
recognize that
i can't speak to the communication
strategy of the company of course which
i know you're not exactly asking me to
do but i will say that
regardless of whether a cyber attack
impacts
a critical infrastructure we take it
seriously and we reserve the option of
responding
in a manner and mechanism of our
choosing
regardless but i think there's no
question that in terms of national
security threats
if it's critical infrastructure and it's
taking out the meat industry
or uh you know suppliers who are
supplying gasoline that is that is
something that is a different impact in
terms of a national security threat
before the u.s retaliates though
is the president's briefing and is he
likely to address the issue of those who
are
uh questioning whether a booster shot is
appropriate with the delta variant
and also is he also contemplating um a
position on
mass wearing for transportation like
airplanes and trains and so forth
still in effect but there's been some
talk that might uh be lifted as more
vaccinations
sure i would not anticipate or you
should not anticipate should say that he
would have any new announcements
or guidance on either of those fronts
today uh we certainly
rely on the advice of our health and
medical experts um
if they're if any of those should change
in the future go ahead
um sorry exactly so data from israel
shows that the flies are vaccine is less
effective against the delta variant
of preventing infection about 64 of the
time
the administration keeps saying as you
just have during the briefing that
you're confident the people who are
vaccinated are safe but
why is this still the assessment and is
there any concern that mass requirements
were lifted too soon
well first i would say that that's
preliminary data
and the vast majority of data from
a larger assessments and larger um
studies shows that it is quite effective
uh and that is the data
uh from mass larger studies that we are
relying on it's preliminary we'll look
at what the final conclusions say
one more um pope francis is still in the
hospital covering him
the president reached out to him at all
to any contact anything the white house
wanted to say
i don't have any contact to to read out
uh for you uh certainly uh the president
wishes him well and a speedy recovery of
course
go ahead um i wanted to go back to covid
there's been a lot of discussion about
the
delta variant but then there's also been
some international concern about the
lambda variant the world health
organization deemed it a variant of
interest back in june
public health england placed it under
investigation due to international
expansion and then british scientists
are describing mutations
that another study also says could
indicate less efficacy
for the vaccine so what do we know about
lambda is it spreading in the u.s and
have vaccine manufacturers
talk to the administration at all about
protections against it sure
well first public health officials
continue to closely track and monitor
all of the variants as we've seen pop up
over time
and are reviewing the latest data when
it becomes available
i'll certainly leave it to doctors to
discuss this but early data suggests
that
the vaccines continue to work against
the variants including this variant
and that's why we've been focusing so
much on increasing vaccinations across
the country as with every strain getting
vaccinated is the best way to protect
yourself and others from any other covid
strains
but we will continue to assess data as
more widely available data becomes
available
how is the spread of new variants
informing travel restrictions
into other countries from other
countries to the us
well certainly as you may know there are
working groups
and with canada with european uh with
our european partners
and we're working to continue to assess
what criteria would need to be in place
in order to reopen travel and we know
that
in many cases families are separated we
know uh that's a heartbreaking
challenge that a lot of people are
dealing with and a lot of people are
eager to travel be with loved ones or
even
do work travel we understand that we're
eager to do that as well
uh the united states has one of the
highest vaccination rates in the world
um and uh that is something we also
assess as we look at countries and are
making uh
those decisions about reopening travel
but these working
groups are meant to have an open line of
transparent communication with these
countries about
what steps need to be taken and then um
how are these
new variants impacting back to school
plans with a lot of children
still too young to get vaccines how is
that
this new element sort of factoring into
all these plants
well i'd say the good news is that there
are a number of mitigation
measures that have been uh recommended
of course by the cdc
that our department of education has
been working to help local school
districts
implement whether they're social
distancing or mask wearing requirements
ventilation there's money that came from
the american rescue plan to help fund
this
in areas and school districts where they
didn't have the money available
so that is certainly what we expect and
we are looking forward to schools being
reopened in the fall
go ahead thanks jeff i just have a few
follow-ups on the opec
plus talks sure can you tell us which
administration officials have been
engaging with the saudi and uae
governments on this issue
i i don't have more details about the
individuals i can see if there's more
specifics to provide for you
and then on the u.s engagement in the
talks i know that you've said the us
isn't a party to the talks
but have these officials engaged or
encouraged
a specific solution uh such as keeping
production levels
where they are currently through the end
of the year well i would say first
we are engaged directly with them to
hear updates on the conversations that
are happening between the opec members
um i can see of course and we are
constantly monitoring
the price of uh gas uh in this country
and we know the impact of oil prices
around the world is having a direct
impact on that
in terms of uh additional specifics of
the conversations i'm just not going to
have anything more to read out for you
and then lastly is there just gauging
the concern level here at the white
house is there any
chance that president biden would
personally get involved in contacting
these governments
i'm certainly not predicting that at
this moment in time we have high level
officials who are
uh talented and aptly uh engaged uh
with their counterparts and i will see
if there's more specifics we can provide
about who the individuals are
go ahead um a couple of things
when we talk about vaccination rights
what is the end goal
where does the administration decide
things are done or things are as best as
i can
i think our health and medical experts
including dr fauci have made pretty
clear
that we're going to be continuing to
battle the virus for some time
now it when you're vaccinated you can
return to
many versions of normal going to the
park
going to restaurants going to concerts
that is one of the many reasons to get
vaccinated including to protect yourself
from
the virus but our we're going to take it
week by week month by month
right now we're continuing to press to
get more people vaccinated we know that
the rates of
young people under the age of 27 are not
where they need to be or we want them to
be so we'll continue to utilize
the best practices and work in
partnership with health and medical
experts
and meet people where they are to get
the vaccine out to more communities sort
of a personal question here but over the
weekend the president was out kind of
campaign style shaking hands with people
taking selfies
giving hugs lots of personal contact i'm
just wondering
given where kobit is in the country it
is the assessment that we can go back
to totally normal life like hugging
people
um shaking hands with strangers and
that's all perfectly okay
given the rise of other variants well
again i would say the cdc
and our health and medical experts have
provided clear guidance on this and if
you're vaccinated
then certainly you can go out there and
engage with society as the president has
and
no one loves a good rope line like like
president biden uh
so certainly he welcomes the opportunity
to engage directly with
many of the people who elected him to
serve uh the country if you're not
vaccinated
uh then that is certainly a different
circumstance now we also respect and
want to convey we respect
the decision by a range of individuals
whether they're
uh or they have concerns about
health issues in their own family or
themselves to continue to wear a mask or
whatever they may choose
but we go by the guidance of our health
and medical experts and
they've certainly okayed the president
being out there and communicating
and shaking hands and uh glad handing
with uh the american people go ahead
um two questions one on oil prices and
one on sure coveted
on oil prices you've alluded a couple of
times today to the sort of
impact on actual gas prices i think it's
over
three dollars a gallon now um a huge
amount of
travel over the over the holiday weekend
what is the president doing for regular
americans to
try to keep the gas prices down whether
it be engaging with opec but also
is the president considering releasing
from the strategic reserve are there
other
steps that the president can take to
address uh what is obviously a painful
situation and how much does he how do
you guys worry on his behalf
that that it will become a political uh
issue
that uh could be could be damaging to
the president and his party
uh in the in the coming election in 18
months
17 months okay um so
i would say first mike that um the
president wants americans to have access
to affordable and reliable energy
including at the pump and so
that's why our team is constantly
monitoring gas prices and directly
communicating with opec parties to get
to a deal and allow proposed production
increases to move forward and
the reason i've referenced it so many
times is because i think there sometimes
is a misunderstanding of what causes gas
prices to increase and so
to convey to the american people that
we're working on it and certainly the
supply availability of oil
has a huge impact i would also say that
ensuring americans don't bear a burden
at the pump
continues to be a top priority for the
administration writ large that's one of
the core reasons why
uh the president was opposed via mainly
opposed to a gas tax
and any tax and vehicle mileage because
he felt that would fall on the backs of
americans
and that was a bottom line red line for
him in
in terms of additional considerations i
just don't have anything to preview for
you
the one thing that you steadfastly have
stayed away from is any question of
mandating
the virus all right that's sorry the
vaccine um and i guess i i
the question is at what point there was
a there was a
physique manual i think has a new output
out talking about how
there needs to be more aggressive action
taken employers are going to need to
mandate
that their employees take the vaccine
um maybe once the fda has fully cleared
some of the vaccines would this
administer does this administration
envision a point where even if it's not
a federal mandate that every
american has to take it do you do you
uh believe that we're going to have to
get to a point where
schools and employers and colleges and
other
institutions are going to have to
require people to to take the vaccine in
order to get to that next stage to get
beyond
the sort of plateau that we've reached
now well we've always anticipated and
we're already seeing this happen
that some schools universities private
schools
others will require and mandate the
vaccine and we leave it up to them to
make that decision
as well as employers and we know that uh
different companies and private sector
entities
or even learning institutions are making
decisions about how to keep their
communities
safe so i wouldn't predict a federal
mandate
as i'm not suggesting you're asking uh
but uh certainly we're already seeing
that take place
uh in communities across the country
encourage employers
and would you encourage you know schools
colleges to do that
as a way of getting kind of a real
acceleration
of of the vaccine
adoption we're going to leave it up to
them to make these decisions
go ahead sure thanks jeff a question on
nicole hannah jones who passed up a
position
at unc will be teaching down the road at
howard
um she said this morning that it took
protest the threat of legal action
um all this just to get to a 9-4 vote
what does
biden make of the unc process and her
decision and is this an example of the
systemic racism that he promised to heal
well i have not spoken with the
president about the decision
on tenure by by the institution in north
carolina i will say that
the students at howard are quite lucky
to have her as a professor and
in their in their family uh but i think
there's no question
that um there is continues to be
systemic racism
in our country we see that in a range of
sectors including in some learning
institutions
but the president that's why the
president is continuing to make racial
equity and addressing racist real equity
is a central
priority uh and crisis that he would
like to address and focus on as
president
go ahead go ahead right there sorry um
on the family's plan yeah
obviously his vitamin goes tomorrow to
promote his vision
um the white house is still in
negotiations about what is actually
going to make it into the package
um are there certain as with the
infrastructure plan certain core
priorities or red lines that he has
around this package
sure so the you're talking about the
reconciliation package
right okay uh so the president is uh
obviously there's a lot of work that
needs to happen with congress
and uh we expect over the next week
there to be
a lot of behind the scenes uh bill
writing negotiations discussions on
capitol hill long nights lots of coffee
over the course of the next several days
given that leader schumer has
has conveyed that he would like to see
both the reconciliation package
and the infrastructure bill on the floor
in july and we're in july now
in terms of the president's priorities
he has outlined his blueprint in his
budget
that includes the american family's plan
includes uh key components he'll talk
about when he's on the road tomorrow
in illinois it includes an extension of
the child tax credit
includes paid leave it includes
universal pre-k making community college
a reality for americans across the
country it also includes
prioritizing and pushing for components
of the american jobs plan that did not
make it into the infrastructure
final infrastructure bipartisan
agreement so that is
key components of climate tax credits uh
key components that will help address
our climate crisis
also a number of proposals on housing
affordability and accessibility that the
president would like to see
in a final reconciliation process but
will be closely engaged and closely
discussing with members who are writing
the legislation
go ahead april i'm back on the issue of
race in and hypersensitivity
around the issue this president um
ran for office on the issue of race from
charlottesville
with that said there is now an effort on
the hill to strengthen the nation's
oldest federal civil rights law of 1866.
is he
involved in that what is his
conversation about this with senators as
well as
congressional leaders as you talk about
that for them what does he feel about it
well we're very appreciative of the
efforts by a number of the leaders who
are
working in discussions about uh updating
of the oldest civil rights law as you as
you noted
um but in terms of specific
conversations of the president i just
don't have anything to read out free
this is important at this moment
especially to strengthen the nation's
oldest civil rights law
as voting rights is
i don't know what you got collapsed as
policing
is held up um there's a call for
reparations
there's so many things that the
congressional black caucus is trying to
push forward with their agenda
as well as issues these issues seem to
be more civil rights and humanitarian
versus policy is this president
concerned at this time about that does
he think that this will bring more
attention
to those issues also in light of uh kkk
members and white supremacists
uh marching in philadelphia over the
weekend on fourth of july
well i would say first april that as you
know because you've covered
it closely um one of the president's key
priorities one of the key pillars of his
presidency
is racial equity and and updating and
addressing what he feels are systemic
issues in
how we govern and in society and i would
say
to touch on a couple of the things that
you've noted um one on
voting rights um you know we i expect
we'll have some more
announcements to make later this week
about the presidents and the vice
president's
schedule and opportunities they will
take to continue to use their platforms
and the bully pulpit
uh to uh advocate for push for uh
take use every level of government to
move uh those
that initiative or those initiatives i
should say uh forward uh but certainly
uh he will remain engaged closely with
civil rights leaders about the range of
priorities that you just discussed
as well as with leaders in congress um
even though things are
hard and things look uh stalled at
moments he doesn't give up
that's not who he is neither is neither
that who the vice president is so
they'll continue to press on moving all
these agenda items forward we're
concerned by the democratic banks
for the democratic base that feels that
he became president standing on these
pillars and now they're in jeopardy is
there concern by this white house
about what the democratic base is
feeling as they see
voting rights stalled as they see police
installed
as they see issue of reparations not
moving as fast as they want in other
issues
i would say first the president shares
their frustration
about the fact that voting rights making
voting more accessible
to more people across the country is a
no-brainer he agrees with the
frustration
that there are more is more we can do
uh to uh put in place reforms uh on
uh policing something that he feels is
long overdue and he would like to sign a
bill into law
and his role as president is to continue
to use his voice his
the bully pulpit and uh his uh platforms
to advocate for moving these things
forward
go ahead you've said a couple of times
on vaccines that the work continues
across some
months after the july 4 holiday will we
hear from the president today
a new date that is the next target date
to get to a certain percentage of
americans vaccinated is there a new
timeline
i don't expect a new goal to be set
today what i will tell you is that
our work is going to continue person by
person community by community
and we're going to meet people where
they are that's what he's going to talk
about and
uh he's going to continue to use
resources from the
federal government empowering doctors
empowering
key voices in communities and that's
what you'll hear him talk about
earlier about not changing minds i think
it was in response to a question we had
a poll out this weekend with the
washington post that said
three and ten adults say they haven't
gotten the coronavirus vaccine
and definitely or probably will not get
one does the white house have a sense
of a number of how many persuadable
people there actually are out there and
how do you target
just them if you can try and convince
some of them well karen i'd first say if
you go back
to even five or six months ago that
percentage of people
who were not planning to get the vaccine
was even much higher than that
and what we've seen have an impact is as
people get
vaccinated in their communities they
tell their neighbor they tell their
friends
primary care physicians tell people who
are coming to other doctors office to
get checkups pharmacists and communities
are calling
their neighbors and saying come on down
we have vaccines for you
we're seeing the impact of that so we've
seen actually even people who
didn't had no intention of getting the
vaccine for a range of reasons uh maybe
they didn't know how to get it maybe
they didn't know where to get it maybe
they were
scared of the impacts actually get
vaccinated and that to us is an
encouraging sign that we can continue to
press and make progress
moving forward go ahead two questions
first is there a target for hurt
immunity
for vaccines uh is it 75
80 what is that goal for the
administration right now well dr fauci
has addressed this a number of times and
has conveyed that herd immunity is kind
of an outdated term
so we had uh set a goal of reaching 70
of adults
by july 4th we reached that goal of
adults 27 and older
by that date and we're continuing to
press to reach it and we will in the
next couple of weeks
for adults over the age of 18 but our
work doesn't stop there and we are going
to continue to press to get
12 to 18 year olds vaccinated to
continue to
uh work with communities where there's
lower vaccination rates that's one of
the reasons we initiated these um
these for these strike forces to go into
communities and work with them to
determine what they need to take a
localized specific approach that works
with elected officials and communities
but
i don't have a new goal to set for you
we are i would remind all of you that we
are
uh we have reduced the death rate by 90
percent we've reduced the
uh the uh coveted uh uh rate by nine by
more than ninety percent
uh but again we're going to continue to
press ahead even after july 4. so the
other question was
african military leaders say the us
military left the air force base
uh with no warning in the middle of the
night uh why did the u.s
do that is that a sign of a lack of
trust in afghan leaders that
wouldn't give them a heads up on their
departure i would point you to the
department of defense on that uh and the
specific accuracy of those comments
there's a relationship that the white
house has with the afghan leaders i mean
how did you explain that to them and
what was that again i'm only pointing to
the department of defense defense
because they are the leaders on the
ground
who would have handed off uh two afghan
leaders on the ground
please go up oh we're going to just go
around go ahead thank you
another one in afghanistan there's been
a lot of talk understandably about
what is the administration doing and is
it doing enough for the afghan
translators
more broadly with the shift that's
coming now
and the talk about the taliban you know
making a lot of advances pretty quickly
is the finance administration concerned
about
a kind of an exodus of a lot more than
just translators but like a whole bunch
of afghans
some of whom might want to come here and
more probably
a lot of whom might try and make their
way to europe is that something the
president's discussing with european
allies
would the us be opening the doors to
some of these people
are you preparing for an excellence well
well i would say first that
our focus as of now is identifying a
group of
siv applicants who have served as
interpreters and translators
as well as other at risk categories who
have assisted us and as you know but for
everybody else
who hasn't paid us close attention our
plan is to relocate
this group to a location outside of
afghanistan before we complete
our military drawdown by the end of
august
so that's where our focus is on at this
point in time
and of course we are doing that in part
because we know these are individuals
who
help the united states even often at
great risk personal risk
to themselves and their families and
we're going to work every possible
contingency to make sure that we can
help
those who have helped us but that's
really what our focus is at this point
what about the broader concern of an
influx of people trying to reach europe
i i don't have any update on that i'm
happy to talk to our national security
team and see if there's
an assessment or concern there go ahead
to uh job support last friday
maxious reported this morning
double-digit wage growth in four key
sectors
transportation warehousing leisure and
hospitality and yet you talk to any
employer in any of those sectors they'll
tell you it's very difficult to find and
keep
good workers for perhaps low-skilled
low-wage jobs
is the white house uh offering any
advice to those employers at this point
with these wage increases of 15 to 17
already it's still difficult finding
quality workers
it is a workers market right now and i
can't assess industry to industry
without having more details i guess that
would be hard for me to do anyway
but certainly we're seeing people feel
more comfortable rejoining the jobs
market a big factor in our view
is the vaccination rates in lots of
communities across the country
we know that employers are starting to
hire as we've seen from the jobs numbers
which
850 000 jobs last month was a very large
number i will just note since you gave
me the opportunity
in terms of specific industries uh there
are cases where
they need to pay their workers more and
that will make them more competitive and
hiring but
i'd have to get we can follow up after
if there's a specific sector and i'm
happy to ask the economic team about
that go ahead
thanks jen uh the white house common
response team last week said that
there's
setting up the surge these surge
response teams
to go into states and communities but
low vaccination rates and rising cases
where are they going first what states
and local communities are you in touch
with
so we're in touch with a range of
communities i provided an update last
week that we were in touch with
missouri about possibly sending uh some
teams there
i know we had already sent a team
deployed a team to colorado
to collaborate with a local department
of health in mesa county i can see if
there's more
but we're in touch with a range of
officials around the country and we're
eager to have these teams out
helping communities get vaccinated and
protect themselves from the virus
it's particularly bad you approach that
community and you say
we'd like to help well the cdc uh is
deploying these teams so they work with
local communities we can see vaccination
rates and where there are
rising caseloads uh and then work in a
collaborative way with the communities
to deploy the teams
yeah go ahead ready um there's still no
nominee for the doj's and i trust the
leader of ana trust
it's been the longest um that position's
been open since george hw
bush and so i guess just curious if
there's a hold up with that position
there so
what is that uh i would say this is
certainly a position the president
is eager to fill uh as with any
important position in government
he wants to have the right person in
place i don't have anything to predict
for you in terms of the timeline for it
the president promised that the united
states would continue to provide
civilian and
humanitarian assistance in afghanistan
but if the taliban were to take over the
government again
won't those individuals be withdrawn
well first i would say that we have
every intention of continuing an ongoing
president
present in kabul which is continuing
even after we bring
our military uh who are serving a home
by the end of august
uh but we will also continue to be
partners to the afghan government that's
something that
the president reiterated when he met
with leaders just a week and a half ago
that we that includes security
assistance that includes humanitarian
assistance uh and that includes over the
horizon
uh capacity uh to ensure that we are
working to
address any threats that we face that
will continue and we
intend to have a presence on the ground
uh in our embassy there in kabul
it does seem like the taliban is
starting to gain more power and take
over there
what's the united states government
what's president biden willing to do
um after pulling truth well i would
first say if you take us back to when
the president made this decision an
announcement
um we uh he asked his team to do a
clear-eyed assessment not to sugarcoat
it
of what the impact could be of uh moving
uh
withdrawing our troops from afghanistan
after a 20-year war a war that the
president continues to feel
uh does not have a military solution
what the president is continuing to
press on is a political
solution and political negotiations and
discussions which we hope will reconvene
soon
to move toward a political solution on
the ground to bring
greater peace and stability to the
people of afghanistan
that's his hope go ahead thank you jack
so you mentioned two weeks ago that
vaccine sharing to the rest of
the world is not a matter of supply but
overcoming the logistical challenge
now that you've passed the deadline of
june and you've not met the target
of distributing 80 million vaccine doses
what has the administration learned
and will do differently and you have a
new target
for the date of completing those 80
million doses
and then just a follow-up on that for
countries that have
refrigerated refrigeration and
distribution challenges
why is the administration focusing on
pfizer and moderna
rather than johnson johnson and then i
have another question on lgbtq
sure well first let me say that we have
allocated all 80 million doses
and i would say what we have learned
through the process is that there are
logistical challenges because when you
talk about working with countries even
as
we convey to a country we have a million
doses or two million doses
sometimes we have to work through legal
barriers we have to work through
regulatory barriers
there are issues as it relates to
materials needed to distribute these
vaccines and there are also
even transportation issues with
refrigeration uh needed as well
so uh we have we have noted as even as
we've allocated all these doses as we
committed to that
part of it is countries need to be ready
to receive them on the ground
and there is no past precedent for this
so there are certainly lessons that we
have learned and
as we've proceeded we have become these
countries have become more effective and
efficient at receiving these doses
they've worked through the red tape
and that enables us to provide the doses
more easily in the future
in terms of the allocation of doses we
provide what's available
i don't have any more detail for you in
terms of which vaccines as you know we
had a larger
uh percentage of moderna and pfizer
vaccines so
hence uh there are modern and physical
vaccines perhaps going to more countries
around
yeah lgbtq there is a violence in
bilisi georgia yesterday where lgbtq
activists and also journalists were
attacked
now the president has recently vowed to
use u.s diplomacy and foreign assistance
to help promote lgbt rights around the
world how does this translate to the
situation in georgia
would there be any kind of real
repercussions uh for situations like in
georgia and other countries where the
rights of lgbtq and minorities are not
protected
absolutely that's a priority of the
president's priority of the state
department and secretary of state
uh the state department would probably
have more of a specific update of direct
engagement with georgia i don't have any
policy
uh announcements or decisions to preview
for you go ahead thank you
during the weekend there was an attack
target genus military base
in the resort in syria and it's not a
principal question i promise you that's
okay go ahead
does the president believe that his
strategy to counter the
pro-iran militias in iraq and syria is
working
considering his own who authorized the
pentagon to
uh with the second attack that we have
seen in the last few weeks
uh well nadia we uh he uh approved these
strikes uh
one with with the full authority legal
authority u.s legal authority and
international authority uh because in a
way that was proportionate
uh and responded to threats against our
entity u.s men and women serving and
entities that were serving in these
countries
it did not mean we expected everything
to grind to a complete halt
at the time but he still felt it was the
appropriate and proportionate steps and
our
objective continues to be a
de-escalation of violence on the ground
go ahead thank you very much sure thank
you on cyber
president biden and president putin met
three weeks ago
and the first expert level meeting about
ransomware is going to happen next week
that's not what i said actually i said
the meetings are ongoing and there's
another meeting next week on ransomware
has there been a meeting about
ransomware at the upper level since
there have been ongoing cyber and expert
level meetings i don't have an agenda of
each of them to read out for you
not specifically on ransomware i i don't
have anything more than cyber and
and expert level meetings we're not
going to read out the agenda from all of
the meetings i'm frustrated
that the pace seems to be slow in those
negotiations
following this meeting with the russian
president i wouldn't say he would
characterize it that way
the meeting with the russian president
was just a couple of weeks ago
we've had ongoing meetings at an expert
level pretty much since that
point in time and again there's a
another meeting scheduled for next week
uh okay go ahead right there right there
yeah go ahead
thank you so much um another foreign
policy question sure
there was a discussion last year of
arranging a d5 summit meeting
and the idea was to get the leaders of
the
five permanent members of the u.n
security council
together at anga this president biden
interested in something like that in any
chance would he be willing to take part
in
in in in a discussion like that at anger
to discuss rules of the road in light of
the current tensions between the west
and the east
i don't have anything about the unga
schedule to preview for you
quite yet um again there are a range of
engagements we have with
a number of the p5 countries which will
certainly
continue but in terms of a meeting at at
anga i don't have anything to preview
for you
i don't think we're quite at that point
in our planning process quite yet lynn
go ahead
thank you for taking my question some
follow-up i'm sure
i visited two questions let me just give
you both of them to make sure i came in
go ahead i'm not going to cut you
offline i know better than that go ahead
as you know this visit is it's the first
presidential visit yeah
into illinois and kovitt came in just as
he was about to come before the illinois
primary so
crystal lake is really tough political
church for democrats
in the county it's in that henry baden
mass senator durbin ross
representative lauren underwood who
you've mentioned lost
though biden did win crystal lake so
could you just explain a little bit more
how this trip to one of the rudder parts
of the bluish states
in totality can advance the violent
policy and political agenda since
there's no swayable members of congress
they're all for you and then on another
very serious note in chicago it's had
its most violent weekend
this year 104 19 killed i understand
where lori lightfoot will be meeting
with the president and o'hare
i understand the administration did roll
out many things to do
to help combat private cities like
chicago but is there something more
that perhaps the president may be able
to bring or discuss with your lifeboat
when they need to tell them sure well on
your first question lynn i think
uh the president was is eager to visit
mchenry county college which as you know
is located
uh in in crystal lake illinois
and he ran as someone who would
represent not just democrats
not just republicans not just
independents but
all people so i would see this as less
of a political trip
more of his of an opportunity to uh
speak to all americans about
uh why his build back better agenda and
why his effort to make to extend the
child tax credit to make community
college
more affordable to make universal pre-k
a reality is something that
uh many people of all political stripes
should be able to support and
that's the case he'll make tomorrow so
he did last week he did the bipartisan
infrastructure deal and kind of did a
very detailed lay down
you'll see him tomorrow do a very
detailed lay down of the rest of his
buildback better agenda and
what many of you would shorthand as the
reconciliation many components of the
reconciliation
package um but he's also eager to see
congresswoman underwood given she's been
such an advocate for
the expansion of health care making it
more affordable and accessible and
that's something he will continue to
advocate for in this bill
yes you know that's exactly the county
she democrats are trying to get rid of
foreign
so it may not may be
not maybe moved too soon because that
might not be her for counting in the
email
could you clarify uh when i kept before
the briefing i didn't think she had a
speaking role
in the program tomorrow does she find
out
i'll have to check lynn i think so i
wanted to give you all an overview of
kind of why he was going there
but in terms of specific meetings and
the program i think we're still
finalizing all those specific details
well i know that there i believe you
mentioned a greet at the airport uh
so i'll have to check and see how long
uh that is
is allocated uh for that meeting and
certainly he is always receptive to what
any elected official wants to raise and
what they want to discuss
i will note that the president continues
to
work to address violent crime we've seen
raise
go up over the last 18 months around the
country including in
the city of chicago and as you know lynn
from covering this
we see spikes in violent crime typically
during summer months often unfortunately
during holiday weekends and we saw that
over the last
weekend but i will say that he will
continue to advocate for and and the
mayor may want to discuss this i guess
we'll see or not but
uh increases in his budget including an
additional 300 million dollars more for
the cops program
that is then than what uh i would say
was approved in the prior
trump administration uh budget so he uh
he had 237
uh billion in his uh in his million
sorry got a little high there
million in his budget and we had the
president's proposing 537 million in his
budget because he wants
uh cops funding to go out to communities
across the country
he will also continue to work to empower
atf he's proposed an additional 70
million
increase over the last trump budget for
atf to ensure that they have the funding
and resources they need to crack down on
illegal guns and i know gun violence is
a huge driver of the crime
in chicago and finally he's going to
continue to advocate for supporting
evidence-based community violence
intervention programs
that are proven to reduce gun violence
in a range of communities but
i'm sure he'll be happy to discuss
components of his budget she may have
different things on her
agenda when they see each other tomorrow
that is correct thanks everyone so much
have a great day